you know why we're sick of seeing the
same body type Kate Upton has a message
for Victoria's Secret while 50 cent sets
the record straight on his past drama
with Randall Emmet
do you regret taking your beef with
Randall to social media no I've got me
pain right away Kate and 50 were guests
on Sundays watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen where the rapper broke down
at what really happened between him and
Vanderpump rules star Lala
Kent's fiance regarding the unpaid debts
Randall owed 50 which was blasted all
over social media did Randall asked to
borrow money or did you offer we were
actually part ways partnering on and she
division films okay we made profits or
the film but it was positioning himself
publicly as my partner yes but he was
receiving a salary ago out of the
profits did we actually meet for the
company it was about a million three
that he had old and he paid but he a
portion of it was paid out of his
portion of his production okay credit
for power like it's directed straight to
me but he didn't actually give me
anything and I was approaching the MFE
was a partner and on the BMS series also
and I'm like if you don't give me
something I'm gonna pay myself back
before you get a chance to pay me but
when it comes to the current status of
their friendship seems that things are
still a bit icy have you spoken to them
since not will you be attending their
wedding no I'll be there later in the
show Kate got brutally honest when a
caller asked her thoughts on a brand she
used to work with Victoria's Secret
after reports surfaced that the
company's annual Fashion Show might not
be happening this year you have to be
body inclusive now every woman
it soon as fast it's beautiful its
powerful it's amazing the blonde beauty
has always been very open about
inclusivity and body positivity both
online and publicly I've become more
confident to speak my mind and to say
things whenever I feel like they're not
right